okay we now have the first major
election forecast for biden versus trump
in november and it tells us
exactly what i told you last week which
is that donald trump can
easily win this election i'm talking
about the 538 forecast which sort of
synthesizes all the polling information
at the national and state level combines
it with historical data combines it with
other factors it's all analyzed and
out comes a number that tells us how
likely is it that trump will win
and how likely is it that joe biden will
win and these numbers
are then up to us to interpret in this
case the numbers are that 538
gives joe biden a 71 chance of winning
and it gives donald trump a 29 chance of
winning now
careful if you believe this is accurate
it is way too close
to think that anything is remotely
certain in this election 71 to 29
in practical terms is 50 50. now i i
want people to really understand the
math of this
what this means is that if you were to
run a 100 elections with today's inputs
today's inputs in 71 of those hundred
elections
joe biden would win and in 29 of those
hundred elections donald trump would win
if nothing changes now of course if
anything changes between now and
november in the direction of trump that
29
number goes up but forget about that 29
is really really high i mean just apply
it to your life
does anybody get on a plane if there's a
29 chance
uh of a problem with the plane's uh
flight worthiness
of course not does anybody go to a
dentist
and you have them fix a cavity if
there's a 29
chance they make a mistake you would
never go to that dentist
more trivially i don't take a sip of
water
if i think there's a 2.9 percent chance
the water is tainted
never mind 29 so for all intents and
purposes
in terms of our behavior 29 is like 50
50.
and if you need any more convincing
about that
when announcing the forecast nate silver
from 538
actually said coincidentally these
are the exact same odds
as in our final forecast in 2016
which was clinton's 71 chance to win
trump 29 now if you want to do
you know a little bit of multiplication
the odds of trump winning twice in a row
with 29 likelihood is about 8
this is like flipping a coin if you flip
a coin once the odds of heads are 50
if after that first flip you flip it a
second time
the odds of heads on that one flip are
still 50
but if in advance i say to you what are
the odds of heads twice in a row
you multiply 0.5 times 0.5 and you get
25 percent uh similarly
if trump's odds really were 29 in 2016
and they're 29
now in the abstract the odds of
winning twice with 29 odds are about 8
but it doesn't matter it's 29 right now
it's essentially a coin flip from the
standpoint of how we should behave
just vote guys that's it and uh this
reinforces you know when you see biden
plus 12
you might get the impression that we
should be thinking about this
differently it's 50 50. this is a
critical moment
this is not a rehearsal let's not mess
this up
one of our sponsors today is surf shark
a
premium vpn service packed with a ton of
useful
features giving my audience 85
off a two-year plan this is under two
bucks a month plus you'll get
three extra months for free it's 20 20.
if you're not using a vpn you should
really start online government
surveillance is a problem
internet providers can sell your
internet history
big tech companies track what you do
online you can protect yourself against
all of this
just by using a vpn and the one i use is
surf shark
because it comes with all kinds of
special features it's a company you can
trust
with your online privacy surfshark hides
your ip address
removes ads protects you from malware
and phishing attempts and it allows you
to stream content
that's only available in other countries
you can install surf shark on
unlimited devices and surfshark never
monitors or logs
your internet activity surfshark is
giving my audience
85 percent off a two-year plan which
comes out to less than two bucks a month
plus you'll get three extra months for
free
go to surfshark.deals slash
pacman the link is right underneath this
video